einen schönen abend und willkommen zu
zdf heute live die ersten
sondierungsgespräche zwischen spd grünen
und fdp sind abgeschlossen in der dreier
konstellation und die generalsekretäre
bzw der geschäftsführer der grünen
michael kellner die werden jetzt in
diesen sekunden minuten vor die presse
treten wir warten und danach wollen wir
dann das gesagt da einordnen
logischerweise mit unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondenten
beziehungsweise aus unserem
hauptstadtstudio christiane hütter
außerdem und das verspricht in der tat
auch noch brisanz warten wir auf eine
pressekonferenz der cdu mit armin
laschet diese ist angekündigt für 18 uhr
30 der sich womöglich dazu äußern wird
wie eine nachfolge und personelle
neuaufstellung seiner partei aussehen
könnte könnte also sein dass wir dann
gleich nach der ersten pressekonferenz
einen fliegenden wechsel hin zur zweiten
hinlegen müssen aber zunächst warten wir
wie gesagt auf die pressekonferenz der
st noch ist keiner vor die mikrofone
getreten aber meine kollegin christiane
hübscher ist schon an ihrem platz also
vielleicht spekulieren wird zunächst mal
ein bisschen in der tat wir haben
eigentlich uns eingestellt auf diese 3er
pressekonferenz jetzt kam heute
nachmittag die information von seiten
der cdu dass armin laschet sich äußern
wird was weiß man darüber was spekuliert
man in berlin was würde da sagen ja es
ist tatsächlich offensichtlich so
gewesen dass armin laschet heute nach
mittleren der unions fraktionssitzung um
16 uhr die erst mal völlig unspektakulär
angekündigt war das ist also was was
normalerweise immer zu beginn der
legislatur öfter stattfindet dort
angekündigt haben soll dass er sich
zurückziehen wolle das behaupten kreise
wie man immer so schön sagt in berlin er
habe gesagt er wolle einen personellen
neuanfang und er möchte den prozess der
nachfolgersuche selbst steuern wir
wissen wir können doch gar nicht sagen
ob das ein rücktritt wird oder ein
rückzug der sich über mehrere monate
hinziehen kann nämlich genau so lange
wie man eben braucht um dann den
nachfolger oder die nachfolgerin zu
bestimmen
am legend auch gesagt zu haben oder soll
auch gesagt haben er würde an jamaika
trotzdem festhalten an dem an dem
konzept und er würde auch einer
jamaika-koalition nicht im wege stehen
wollen mit einem anderen
führungspersonal dann von seiten der
union
er soll gesagt haben bis ein neuer
kanzler gewählt ist ist alles offen das
sorgt jetzt natürlich gerade in berlin
für wahnsinnig viel wirbel und trubel
alle sind auf dem weg ins konrad
adenauer haus wo armin laschet um 18.30
diese pressekonferenz geben will
zeitgleich du hast gesagt christof
findet jetzt gleich auch diese
pressekonferenz der drei
generalsekretäre der beiden
generalsekretäre und des
bundesgeschäftsführers der ampel
parteien statt der möglichen
ampelkoalition
und ich spiele hier immer so ein
bisschen auf mehrere bildschirme sollen
nicht wie so was jetzt was jetzt als
erstes beginnt also da überschlagen sich
tatsächlich die ereignisse aber
tatsächlich die dieser angekündigte
laschet rückzug das ist jetzt natürlich
ein
das ist ein ding in der tat wenn es dann
so kommen sollte glaubst du das ist
zufall dass das jetzt zeitlich so
zusammenfällt oder wollte man da
irgendwie sich gegenseitig die show
stehlen wie glaubst du ist das
einzuschätzen ich glaube armin laschet
will niemanden mehr die schau stehlen
würde ich sagen ich glaube der druck ist
einfach zu groß geworden nach elf tagen
nach der bundestagswahl in dem er ja
mehr oder weniger offen auch aus der aus
den eigenen reihen jetzt irgendwie dazu
aufgerufen worden ist den platz
freizumachen
es hat gestern noch einmal für viel
wirbel gesorgt dass markus söder gesagt
hat de facto seite erledigt und auch
alexander dobrindt hat ja armin laschet
noch mal aufgefordert die realitäten zu
akzeptieren so hat er das gesagt also
man konnte davon ausgehen dass die csu
nicht mehr wirklich gar nicht mehr zu
armin laschet und dieser jamaika idee
steht dass sie die für nicht mehr
realistisch hält und es hat auch andere
stimmen gegeben tatsächlich in der union
also der innenminister
genauso wie der gesundheitsminister
laumann aus nrw haben sich solidarisch
mit mit laschet erklärt haben gesagt sie
üben kritik an dem innerparteilichen
umgang mit dem mit dem kandidaten und
hätten sich da mehr unterstützung
gewünscht aber ganz offensichtlich ist
der druck jetzt doch so groß von innen
und von außen dass armin laschet jetzt
wohl offensichtlich die reißleine zieht
ja offenbar jetzt ist es so du hast es
angekündigt er hat in seinem statement
so ist es zumindest jetzt kolportiert
worden hat er gesagt oder wird er dann
sagen dass jamaika damit noch nicht
endgültig vom tisch sei wenn auch
eventuell ohne ihn andersrum die csu er
sehr zurückhaltend was dieses thema
angeht du hast auch noch meine herrn
söder zitiert der gestern ja dazu was
gesagt hat also platz christopher geht
es glaube ich los nr handlung ist
absolut berechtigt also im prinzip
nimmst du mir die worte aus dem untersee
ist jetzt auch gerade wir gehen nach
berlin und hören uns an was die drei
sender zu sagen haben danach reden wir
weiter
ersten dreier gespräch heute zwischen
spd grüne und fdp es beginnt lars
klingbeil generalsekretär der spd dann
folgt volker wissing generalsekretär der
fdp und im anschluss michael kellner der
bundesgeschäftsführer der grünen wir
lassen danach eine begrenzte anzahl von
fragen zu erklingen bitte darf sie alle
recht herzlich begrüßen sie können sich
vorstellen dass das für uns ein
besonderer tag war elf tage nachdem wir
bei der bundestagswahl auf platz eins
die wahl gewonnen haben sind wir heute
in 3er gespräche eingestiegen bin den
kollegen von der fdp stellvertretend
volker wissing den kollegen von den
grünen stellvertretend michael kellner
sehr dankbar dafür dass wir den heutigen
tag in intensiven gesprächen gut
vorbereitet haben dass wir das sehr
vertrauensvoll vorbereitet haben heute
jetzt aber hier zu dritt zusammen
gekommen sind und ich darf ihnen sagen
das war ein gespräch das intensiv war
das s gekennzeichnet war von einer
ernsthaft
gesprächsatmosphäre auch wir wissen dass
wir um große herausforderung für unser
land hier reden aber es war ein gespräch
das geprägt war davon dass wir gemeinsam
etwas erreichen wollen ich habe gespürt
in dem gespräch dass wir was gemeinsames
schaffen können und es geht auch und
auch das wurde deutlich heute es geht
darum dass man mit einem politischen
stil jetzt in die gespräche reingeht der
nicht von gewinnern und verlierern
geprägt ist sondern der dafür sorgt dass
am ende alle parteien eine regierung
gemeinsam bilden alle parteien auch ihre
schwerpunkte setzen können wir insgesamt
aber die großen
zukunftsherausforderungen dieses landes
anpacken das was wir verabredet haben
aufgrund des guten gesprächs heute ist
dass es ab montag weitergehen wird dass
wir jetzt das wochenende nutzen um eine
intensive woche auch der sondierung
vorzubereiten dass wir am montagmorgen
dann wieder zusammenkommen in der runde
mit grünen und fdp und
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
und die themen die wir heute
angesprochen haben und ich darf ihnen
sagen es waren alle themen auf den tisch
wir haben heute nicht mit
höflichkeitsfloskeln angefangen und die
ausgetauscht sondern wir haben wirklich
über alle themen gesprochen dass wir die
nächste woche dann nutzen werden um
diese themen auch intensiv weiter zu
beraten und dann auch zur einigung zu
kommen vielen dank
ja meine damen und herren wir haben
heute zum ersten mal zu dritt zusammen
gesessen und haben vertieft die breite
der themen miteinander besprochen das
gespräch ist sehr gut verlaufen
alle gesprächspartner haben mit dem
notwendigen ernst und auch mit einer
klaren bereitschaft zusammen gesprochen
jetzt die gespräche weiter zu vertiefen
die fdp hat im anschluss an dieses erste
dreier treffen eine präsidiumssitzung
hier vor ort durchgeführt wir haben dort
berichtet über den verlauf des gesprächs
und dem präsidium vorgeschlagen jetzt in
eine förmliche vertiefte
sondierungsphase
in dem in der dreier konstellation
einzutreten diese wird in der nächsten
woche stattfinden das heutige gespräch
war nicht nur von der themenbreite her
wichtig es war auch wichtig weil wir von
einander wissen wollen oder wissen
wollten ob wir die bereitschaft haben
mit viel ernst und auch mit ja ich sage
mal gegenseitigem verständnis für die
unterschiede sich auf den weg zu machen
ein gemeinsames regierungsprogramm für
die bundesrepublik deutschland zu suchen
alle wissen es sind unterschiedliche
politikansätze die hier miteinander ins
gespräch gekommen sind es gibt themen
bei denen wird es nicht einfach und umso
wichtiger war es für uns in einem dreier
gespräch
herauszufinden ob es die bereitschaft
gibt auch größere hürden gemeinsam zu
nehmen das haben wir heute gesehen und
dementsprechend unserem präsidium die
vertiefte sondierung empfohlen das
präsidium ist dem vorschlag der
parteiführung
einstimmig folgt wir werden jetzt das
wochenende nutzen um die gespräche in
der kommenden woche
sorgfältig vorzubereiten wir wollen das
konzentriert tun wir wollen nicht um die
dinge herum reden sondern wir wollen sie
konkret ansprechen und nach lösungen
suchen
das heutige gespräch macht mut dass das
möglich ist wenngleich wir wissen es ist
ein schwieriger weg aber wir spüren die
erwartungen und die hoffnungen die
menschen in uns gesetzten und weil uns
das verbindet bin ich zuversichtlich
dass die nächste woche eine gute werden
kann jetzt kommt es auf eine
detaillierte vorbereitung an das wird
auf arbeits ebene erfolgen und dann geht
es am montag um glaube ich früh 9 uhr
geht es weiter
ja einen wunderschönen guten abend auch
von mir herzlichen dank an volker
wissing herzlichen dank an die fdp für
die entscheidung das war heute ein guter
tag und wir starten nächste woche
ab montag mit vertieften sondierung und
ich glaube man hat das schon in den in
den zweier gesprächen gemerkt
das ist eine vertrauensbasis da man kann
vertraulich und vertrauensvoll
miteinander reden über alle themen
natürlich das ja auch klar ist da noch
ein ganzes stück des weges zu gehen aber
ich glaube lösung lassen sich finden
lösungen lassen sich finden für die
probleme unseres landes gemeinsam in
einer konstellation
wie sie es auf bundesebene ja noch nie
gab und deswegen würde ich auch sagen
das ist bei allen auseinandersetzungen
im wahlkampf ein starkes zeichen dass so
unterschiedliche parteien vertrauensvoll
miteinander reden können und deswegen
haben wir auch diese vereinbarung dass
wir sagen wir wollen keine
zwischenstände
herausgeben sondern weiterhin in diesem
geist es dass die zusammenarbeit der
vertrauensvollen zusammenarbeit weiter
arbeiten
so jetzt ist zeit für ihre fragen die
erste frage geht an achim unser von welt
der kollege kommt der kollege
ist das schon ganz okay was mich
interessieren würde an alle drei
generalsekretäre vielleicht sie ziehen
ja so ein positives fazit aber darf man
sich das vorstellen dass sie da auch
unter umständen schon inhaltlich von dem
einen oder anderen punkt nicht abgerückt
aber signale gegeben haben ja da können
wir uns vielleicht auch was anderes
vorstellen da können wir uns aufeinander
zu bewegen ist das schon in dieser art
diskutiert worden und dann hätte ich
noch eine frage an volker wissing der
armee laschet kündigt ja offensichtlich
in wenigen minuten da seinen rückzug an
will nur noch modell gerieren ist für
sie haben sich ja jamaika immer noch
theoretisch auf ungehalten ist mit
jamaika endgültig vom tisch oder würde
das unter umständen jamaika vielleicht
auch neu beflügeln
zunächst einmal zu ihrer ersten frage es
wird keine zwischen einigungen geben
können die bandbreite der themen muss
insgesamt
besprochen werden und deswegen streben
wir keine zwischenlösungen an sondern
wir streben an dass wir ein sondierungs
ergebnis am ende dieses formalen prozess
bekommen dem wir nächste woche beginnen
und insofern kann es nicht
zwischenschritte geben
wir haben das zur kenntnis genommen das
ist ganz offensichtlich in der cdu jetzt
nicht nur diese schwierigen öffentlichen
debatten gab sondern dass es auch
veränderungen an der spitze geben wird
wir haben aber immer klar gestellt dass
unsere messlatte für die bildung einer
regierung nicht personen sind sondern
inhalte sind und deswegen ist das etwas
was wir natürlich wahrnehmen und das
muss man auch ernst nehmen natürlich
führt auch ein personeller wechsel auch
zu einer neuen perspektive auf eine
partei aber für uns bleibt klar eine
regierungsbildung kann sich nicht an
einzelnen personen oder parteiinternen
führungsfragen entscheiden sondern sie
muss sich an inhalten festmachen und wir
haben jetzt heute einen ganzen tag uns
mit inhalten für die bundesrepublik
deutschland beschäftigt wird die für die
frage welche richtung soll dieses land
das ja einen bedeuten dass in europa ist
regiert werden und das ist das worauf
wir uns konzentrieren werden dabei
bleibt es und wir haben ja festgelegt
die reihenfolge der gespräche ist klar
wir werden jetzt ab montag diese
gespräche mit der spd und bündnis 90/die
grünen vertiefen und sehen eine
perspektive dass wir zu einem
gemeinsamen weg kommen können ob das der
fall ist wissen wir am ende des
prozesses
heßler vom tagesspiegel bitte
ich habe volker wissing nichts
hinzuzufügen bei der ersten frage das
zeigt ja auch dass das sehr harmonisch
wie heute dann würde ich gerne auch
nochmal an herrn wissing und auch in
einem kellner fragen wenn es jetzt bei
der union und auch gerade bei der cdu zu
einer art führungsvakuum kommt ist dann
nicht de facto jamaika so unrealistisch
geworden das ist eigentlich keine
aussicht mehr gibt diese koalition
vielleicht anzugehen und ich hätte eine
organisatorische frage vielleicht
anerkennen bei mit blick auf die
kommende woche und sie können eine sehr
intensive sondierungs woche an aber
dazwischen steht glaube ich noch eine
reise des vize-kanzlers nach washington
und da würde mich interessieren welche
termine gibt es nach dem montag und wann
wir haben jetzt entschieden dass wir in
dieser konstellation vertieft sondieren
und während dieser sondierungsphase
führen wir keine parallelen
verhandlungen das verbietet sich das
macht auch ein vertrauensvolles sprechen
in dieser konstellation nicht wirklich
besser deswegen gibt es keine parallelen
verhandlungen gegeben und zufolge dessen
stellt sich für mich auch nicht parallel
die frage was bedeutet ein
führungswechsel bei der union für eine
mögliche regierungsbildung diese frage
wer stellt sich die nächste woche nicht
ja ich finde auch dass der respekt vor
den entscheidungen der cdu auch
erstmalig gerne abwarten würde was die
cdu entscheidet aber das ist doch klar
dass wir hier heute zusammengekommen
sind um zwischen diesen drei parteien
vertiefte gespräche zu führen das war
heute ein sehr gutes gespräch und wir
werden damit ab montag weiter machen und
es wird es keine da kann ich mich nur
den ausführungen von herrn bisschen
anschließen es wird ja keine parallelen
gespräche geben das wäre nun glaube ich
der falsche weg
also zur frage wie das nächste woche
abläuft wir haben für montag einen sehr
intensiven verhandlungstag verabredet
wir haben den dienstag bis mittags
verabredet wir haben verabredet dass wir
dann am freitag auch sondieren werden es
ist aber auch deutlich geworden heute
dass das regierungshandeln da geht und
alle haben verständnis dafür gezeigt
dass olaf scholz nächste woche in
washington sein wird das sind wichtige
termine die nimmt erhält vizekanzler
finanzminister natürlich war und wir
werden die zeit denn das darf ich glaube
ich nur sagen als generalsekretär auch
nutzen um intensiv dann weiter zu
arbeiten derzeit die kollegin von dpa
vorher zog
hecking war hier wissen sie haben sich
jetzt beide explizit auf die kommende
woche bezogen die sie vorbereiten wollen
dass er eine wichtige sanierungs woche
kann man es so verstehen dass sie am
ende dieser woche möglicherweise auch so
weit sein wollen dass sie über mögliche
koalitionsverhandlungen entscheiden
können
also wir haben jetzt erst mal und
darüber sind wir sehr froh entschieden
dass wir am montag in intensive
sondierungs gespräche eintreten wir
haben da einige dinge zu klären und wir
sind fertig mit den sondierungen wenn
wir fertig sind da nehmen wir uns die
notwendige zeit ich glaube wir alle
haben gelernt aus vorangegangenen
verhandlungsrunden dass man sondierung
auch auf ein mindestmaß beschränken
sollte aber wir nehmen uns die zeit die
wir brauchen und dann hoffen wir
natürlich dass es dann zügig in
koalitionsverhandlungen
ich kann mich dem anschließen es gibt
kein vereinbart das ende der
sondierungsgespräche
aber wir gehen anders vor als wir das
vielleicht in der ein oder anderen
stelle in der vergangenheit erlebt hat
wir treffen uns am montag nicht um erst
mal locker zu plaudern mal zu schauen
wie weit wir kommen und wohin sich das
entwickelt sondern wir legen größten
wert darauf dass die gespräche sehr
strukturiert geführt werden und auch
thematisch auf den punkt geführt werden
und sie können sich das so vorstellen
ich glaube das kann man sagen dass wir
themen jetzt
identifizieren und den themen auch ein
zeitfenster zu weisen und dann diese
themen nacheinander besprechen werden
dann werden wir eine pause brauchen um
zu evaluieren wo gibt es noch weiteren
gesprächsbedarf und
dementsprechend haben wir nach einem
solchen muster die die tage der nächsten
woche
strukturiert und dann kommen wir
untereinander zu der beantwortung der
frage brauchen wir noch zusätzliche zeit
oder nicht aber diese frage kann ich
jetzt nicht beantworten
das macht jetzt auch keinen sinn mehrere
wochen durch zu strukturieren weil wir
der meinung sind dass die zeit reicht um
den ersten durchgang durch die themen zu
machen nächste woche und wo wir dann
stehen das wissen wir heute nicht aber
dass wir das strukturiert und
organisiert und gut organisiert und
vorbereitet führen werden das ist uns
sehr wichtig weil wie gesagt wir haben
schon erfahrungen gemacht in einer
versuchten dreier konstellation wo das
lockerer darauf los reden in
unterschiedlichsten runden und gremien
und arbeitsgruppen so viel arbeit aber
zu wenig ergebnis geführt hat das darf
sich nicht wiederholen
denn das land muss regierungsfähig sein
und der auftrag den die wählerinnen und
wähler uns gegeben haben ist ein
wahrlich schwieriger ein komplexer
auftrag das wissen alle umso wichtiger
ist es dass er sehr gut vorbereitet und
strukturiert abgearbeitet wird und wenn
ich dann noch einen gedanken dazu fügen
dafür wir uns glaube ich auch einig sind
dass so ein system man führt jetzt
nachts bis zur erschöpfung und wundert
sich dann zwei tage später was man
eigentlich gesprochen hat dass wir sehr
konzentriert sehr intensiv arbeiten
wollen aber dass wir nicht das perfekt
für sie auch eine ganz schöne nachricht
ich weiß es nicht aber das nicht unser
ziel ist einfach nachdem motors
irgendwann ist man so erschöpft an dann
gibt es ein ergebnis sondern sehr
konzentriert tagsüber arbeiten und das
verständigen und diese nachtsitzung die
unseres erachtens glaube ich politik
nicht besser machen das wird die nächste
woche im nicht anlegen zur letzte frage
bezüglich die fahren ja
holger möhle bonner general anzeiger
welche harten fakten oder themen wollen
sie am montag ansprechen wenn sie uns
einfach mal ein zwei spiele gehen können
damit man so formal betrachten dieses
konkrete kriegt und dann noch eine frage
sie versuchen sich ja in einer
annäherung zur tritt jetzt bislang zu
zweit wie weit hat sie dieses
dreiertreffen im vergleich zu den zwei
treffen überhaupt voran gebracht oder
sind sie noch eine beim versuch der
annäherung an derselben stelle
also wenn ich darf würde ich das so
beantworten dass die zwei jahre
gespräche die er doch recht zahlreich
stattgefunden haben letzte woche
dass die aus meiner perspektive dass die
vertrauen aufgebaut haben ja durchaus in
einer situation die die nicht einfach
ist dann muss man nicht drum herum reden
das ist zum ersten mal dass drei
parteien ja nicht zum ersten mal aber
wir wollen das mit drei parteien
schaffen das ist eine neue situation die
letztes mal 2017 nicht funktioniert hat
wir haben den festen willen das diesmal
hinzubekommen die konstellation der zwei
jahre gespräch hat ganz viel vertrauen
aufgebaut dass wir heute auch spürbar
dass da schon diese zwar gespräche
stattgefunden haben und was die konkrete
tagesordnung für montag angeht da bitte
ich um verständnis dass wir uns darauf
geeinigt haben dass wir zwischen stellen
die nicht rausgeben dass wir genau diese
punkte nicht rausgeben das ist der geist
der gespräche die wir führen wollen dass
wir sagen wir klären dinge unter uns wir
klären sie vertrauensvoll und sie werden
das hoffentlich gute ergebnisse dann
rechtzeitig mitbekommen
dann vielen dank für ihr kommen
soweit also die pressekonferenz der drei
generalsekretäre beziehungsweise des
geschäftsführers der grünen wir fast an
das geschehene noch mal ganz kurz
zusammen also das gespräch war intensiv
ernsthaft und wollen gemeinsam etwas
erreichen so lars klingbeil von der spd
insgesamt kann man sagen dass alle drei
redner relativ optimistisch geklungen
haben was diesen ersten dreier dieser
erste dreier konstellation angeht ab
montag soll es dann weitergehen volker
wissing von der fdp hat noch mal gesagt
die gespräche seien sehr gut verlaufen
ernst aber auch eben mit bereitschaft
und auch die eigene präsidiumssitzung
hätte dann dort den vorschlag abgenickt
zur offiziellen sondierung die dann am
montag beginnen sollen auch michael
kellner von den grünen hat sich dem
positiven fazit angeschlossen es sei ein
guter tag gewesen die vertrauensbasis
sei da und lösungen würden sich wohl
finden lassen wir gucken an der stelle
vielleicht gerade noch mal rüber zur cdu
denn da ist ja für 18 uhr 30 ein
statement von armin laschet angekündigt
und wir sind natürlich sehr gespannt was
er dann dort sagen wird es ist die rede
davon dass er sich zumindest einen
rückzug offen hält ihn vielleicht sogar
auch schon ankündigt das ist eine
personelle neuausrichtung in der cdu
geben könnte das dann ab 18 30 und bis
dahin sprechen wir weiter mit unserer
kollegin im hauptstadtstudio mit
christiane hütter vielleicht gerade noch
mal dein eindruck der drei herren die
wir gerade gehört haben wie haben sie
auf dich gewirkt traute dreisamkeit
würde ich sagen na ähnlich wie du das
gerade beschrieben hat christopher also
da war viel die rede von wir haben wir
brauchen keine höflichkeitsfloskeln
sondern das war ein guter tag war ein
vertrauensvoller tag ich finde aus der
beobachter perspektive dass die sehr
vieles sehr viel anders machen als es
2017 gelaufen ist das geht damit los
dass man keine zwischenergebnisse
verraten will also jeder der erwartet
hat dass das sie jetzt raus kommen und
sagen also es gibt ein tempolimit oder
es gibt kein tempolimit der sieht sich
getäuscht
ja sie lassen da wirklich keine luft
dran und das hat aber auch einen guten
grund denn das sind alles dinge die 2017
glaube ich nicht so gut gelaufen sind da
ist ja während dieser jamaika sondierung
ständig die zwischenergebnisse
durchgestochen worden per sms raus an
die an die journalisten und dann wusste
man schon aber das kommt und das ist
geeint und das ist noch nicht geeint das
ist strittig darüber zerlegen die sich
gerade da drin und genau diesen eindruck
will man eben diesmal nicht erwecken
sondern man sagt wir wollen konzentriert
einen fahrplan abarbeiten man hat auch
jetzt mehr haben sie ja eigentlich nicht
gesagt ein fahrplan erstellt für nächste
woche ab montag geht es los ich glaube
am montag am dienstag und am freitag
soll jetzt vertieft sondiert werden so
wird es bezeichnet und was auch anders
ist es wird keine lange nachtsitzungen
mehr geben sagte ja gerade der grüne
michael kellner noch mal auch im
unterschied zu 2017 wo wir journalisten
ja zum teil bis morgens halb fünf in der
kälte im november draußen vor der
parlamentarischen vertretung direkt
gegenüber vom bundestag gestanden haben
und dann irgendwann morgens halb fünf
todmüde politiker raus wanken und gesagt
haben ja also es noch ein weiter weg ja
das will man das will man eben diesmal
nicht sondern man strukturiert das sehr
klar man gibt ihm ein zeitfenster pro
thema und will schauen ob man da zu
einer einigung kommt
ja also ich finde das lässt sich erst
mal genommen zu hause gesehen ganz gut
anja lässt sich gut hören ich nehme an
auch die hauptstadt kollegen sind nicht
wirklich böse wenn die nacht sitzungen
klare
ansage jetzt erstmal unterbleiben das
war wahrscheinlich für alle beteiligten
damals doch relativ kräften anstrengend
raubend ja das kann ich mir vorstellen
der eine oder andere mag sich gefragt
haben warum jetzt eigentlich die
generalsekretäre bzw der geschäftsführer
vor die kameras getreten sind und nicht
die parteivorsitzenden hat dass
irgendeine tiefere bewandtnis naja ich
glaube aus genau dem grund dass man eben
inhaltlich noch gar nichts zu verkünden
hat na also dass es hier darum geht
sozusagen eine gesprächsatmosphäre
erstmal grundsätzlich kurz zu
beschreiben das haben die drei gemacht
und einen fahrplan für die nächsten
wochen zu verkünden ja und zu sagen wir
gehen jetzt in diese vertieften
sondierungen und das ist klassische
organ arbeit sag ich mal so und das
machen natürlich am besten
generalsekretäre und
bundesgeschäftsführer wie in diesem fall
und dazu kommt auch noch wenn wir immer
auf die
parteivorsitzenden hier warten müssten
dann wäre das ganz schön viele nämlich
fünf an der zahl wenn wir uns überlegen
dass es die doppelspitze bei der bei den
grünen gibt und die doppelspitze bei der
spd und dazu noch christian lindner und
außerdem oder falls könnte dann gar
nicht dabei sein weil obwohl er ja hier
sozusagen ich würde sagen der
chefunterhändler für die für die
spd-seite ist aber er ist eben nicht der
parteivorsitzende sondern das sind
saskia esken und norbert walter borjans
ja also wie gesagt da relative einigkeit
und du sprichst du es anders wäre
vielleicht doch in der tat etwas
schwierig die alle unter einen hut zu
bekommen zumindest für jede
pressekonferenz ja dann werden wir
sicher später noch erleben aus big shots
so lange raus kann wenn es wirklich was
zu verkünden gibt aber hier geht erstmal
um familien interessanterweise sind die
drei insbesondere herr wissing natürlich
auch auf das angekündigte statement von
armin laschet angesprochen worden wie
gesagt wir warten 18.30 soll es sein
auch er wurde mit der frage konfrontiert
was das denn jetzt bedeuten würde für
die drei sondiere wenn jetzt die cdu
sich doch dann ernsthaft sozusagen als
möglicher ansprechpartner verabschieden
sollte das ist ja noch nicht ganz raus
aber die zeichen deuten darauf hin dass
das dann eher schwieriger würde mit der
union und da hat er gesagt ja es geht
nicht so sehr um personen sondern um
inhalte nimmst du ihm das ab es ist ja
schon eine schwächung denke ich der
position von fdp und grünen oder nicht
ja die fdp bleibt da einfach bei ihrem
wedding was sie ja auch gestern schon
gezeigt hat nämlich dass sie gesagt für
uns geht es hier nicht um personen wir
nehmen das zur kenntnis was da passiert
bei der union aber man sieht eben in der
fdp nach wie vor die größten
inhaltlichen schnittmengen tatsächlich
mit der union und sagt eben im grunde
genommen jamaika hängt für uns nicht von
armin laschet ab man will sich diese
kleine hintertür doch noch offen halten
und sagt eben wir vertiefen jetzt die
ampel sondierungen es wird keine
parallel gespräche geben das hat da auch
noch mal betont sowie dass er christian
lindner gestern schon gesagt hat aber
man will es auch nie ganz ausschließen
und und sagt eben nicht nur weil amila
steht jetzt womöglich den rückzug
antritt und eine andere führungsfigur
kommen könnte hat sich diese idee für
uns komplett erledigt das sagt er
ausdrücklich nicht wobei man ja schon
sagen muss dass armin laschet wir gucken
vielleicht gerade noch mal auf das noch
verwaiste rednerpult also sie sehen wir
sind vor ort wir gucken immer drauf sie
werden es nicht verpassen wenn er dann
vor die mikrofone tritt
vielleicht einmal zur person armin
laschet er ist natürlich schon auch
immer sehr mit jamaika verbunden worden
was natürlich auch an der situation
liegt dass er mit der fdp in nordrhein
westfalen so relativ harmonisch
zusammengearbeitet hat das sein gutes
verhältnis zu christian lindner hat also
insofern das ist ja schon auch verbunden
gewesen mit seinem namen könnte man da
jetzt einfach irgendwie die personen
austauschen ich schätze dass ein
stimmen in berlin die gesagt haben wenn
jemanden jamaika verhandeln könnte dann
wäre das armin laschet weil er ebenso
verbinden des ausgleichendes temperament
offensichtlich hat und verschiedene
seiten an einem tisch die nicht alle das
gleiche wollen gut zusammenbringen könne
jetzt ist es aber wie es ist
offensichtlich und
dieser dieser dieser misserfolg bei der
wahl bringt ihnen womöglich doch zum
rückzug und
ja also hält man hört nichts sagen wir
mal so von all den figuren und
politikern von denen man jetzt natürlich
gerne hören würde es gibt noch keine
tweets keine äußerungen von friedrich
merz von markus söder von jens spahn
aber wir können sicher sein glaube ich
dass das nicht lange dauern würden dann
hören wir von denen und dann wenn wir
erfahren ich musste ich probiert und
sich auch diesmal darf ich sozusagen
darauf hinweisen dass herr laschet jetzt
ans pult tritt und wir haben rein
die vor sondierungen mit der fdp und den
grünen waren gute konstruktive gespräche
wir haben klar anerkannt dass es eine
neue situation für die regierungsbildung
gibt wir haben die wahl nicht gewonnen
wir haben nicht platz eins sondern platz
zwei und wir erkennen an dass fdp und
grüne entscheiden mit wem sondiert wird
wenn man den gesprächen die zahlreichen
gemeinsamkeiten aufgezeigt dagegen
setzten die bereitschaft zum kompromiss
signalisiert
und unseren willen und unsere lust für
ein neues politik projekt deutlich
gemacht dass wurde im nachgang auch von
fdp und grünen bestätigt aber es geht
jetzt nicht darum welche partei oder
welche person in die regierung kommt
sondern welche politik die nächsten vier
jahre gemacht wird das ist der grund
weshalb ich mich für jamaika einsätze
zwar ist die chance für einen echten
aufbruch in unserem land schwer ein
ambitioniertes modernisierungs bündnis
mit breiter gesellschaftlicher
verankerung jamaika hat mit der union
einen anker vor ort in den städten und
gemeinden in den ländlichen räumen in
den urbanen räumen in ost und west in
der wirtschaft beim handwerk bei der
landwirtschaft bei jung und alt
und jamaika hat einen starken partner im
bundesrat ferner könnte eine menge sehr
schnell umsetzen mit cdu fdp cdu grünen
und jamaica regierungen und wenn es fdp
und grüne nun einen aufbruch und
ambition geht ist die spd der falsche
partner
das können wir aus langjährige
regierungserfahrung
bestätigen vor diesem hintergrund gibt
es zumindestens berechtigte fragen warum
ohne not in einseitige
sondierungsgespräche gestartet worden
ist wir von uns schlagend keine tür zu
entscheidungsgrundlage einer regierung
für vier jahre in dieser situation
müssen die ziele der nächsten vier jahre
sein und nicht tagesaktuelle stimmungen
und in diesem sinne das angebot der cdu
deutschlands steht bis zur letzten
sekunde der regierungsbildung
und die gründe von
fdp und grünen die jamaika optionen auch
für möglich erachtet haben gelten weiter
und deshalb
werden wir jetzt genau beobachten wie
die vertieften gespräche zu denen fdp
und grüne sich heute für die nächste
woche verabredet haben wie die verlaufen
wie das beispielsweise in der steuer
finanz und haushaltspolitik
funktionieren soll die fdp war für eine
absenkung der unternehmenssteuer um
wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu erhöhen um
arbeitsplätze zu sichern
für die abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlags für erweiterte und
beschleunigte abschreibung gegen eine
vermögenssteuer für die beibehaltung des
ehegattensplittings gegen eine
schuldenunion für die einhaltung der
schuldenbremse und und und und deshalb
werden wir sehr aufmerksam in der
nächsten woche die beratung und
verfolgen das gleiche gilt für die
mitarbeiterbeteiligung beispielsweise
bei startups eine ganz wichtige frage
für die start up kultur und start up
szene ebenso wie beim bürokratieabbau
entfesselung alles themen die in den
letzten jahren der großen koalition
mühsam mit der fdp mit der spd zu
bewegen waren
das gleiche gilt beim klimaschutz wir
brauchen mehr tempo und
deshalb werden wir mit unseren ideen
bereit stehen aber
viele zitieren immer immer wieder diesen
spruch erst das land dann die partei
dann die person bei dem thema könnte man
das einmal belegen wo ist die größte
stabilität möglich
und wir signalisieren
fdp und grünen
ansprechpartner für die cdu bleibt der
cdu vorsitzende dafür habe ich die
rückendeckung von partei und fraktion
und es wird nicht am ansprechpartner
scheitern wenn man ein neues projekt
beginnt es gibt wertschätzung auch in
den persönlichen gesprächen von fdp und
grünen gegenüber meiner person
aber ich habe bereits in den gesprächen
deutlich gemacht an der person wird es
nicht scheitern
das habe ich heute auch der fraktion
berichtet es geht nicht um die person
armin laschet es geht um das projekt für
das land und deshalb wenn man zu anderen
lösungen kommen will ist dies möglich
das große projekt jamaica wird nicht am
personal scheitern wird nicht an
einzelnen personen scheitern es ist eine
große aufgabe vor der wir stehen und
dieses signal ist
bereits in den gesprächen dieser woche
übermittelt worden ist auch im unions
internen kreis übermittelt worden und
die darüber habe ich heute der fraktion
berichtet das ist der prozess
regierungsbildung jamaika eine andere
frage ist die frage welche konsequenzen
zieht die cdu aus dem wahlergebnis
sowohl für die theoretische möglichkeit
einer regierungsbeteiligung als auch für
die möglichkeit der opposition und wir
müssen dieses wahlergebnis aufarbeiten
und die neuaufstellung der cdu
vorantreiben meine feste überzeugung
bleibt dabei
erneuerung geht auch in der regierung
geht sogar besser in der regierung geht
aber auch in der opposition und zur
aufarbeitung des wahlergebnisses hat
generalsekretär
zenit bereits ein maßnahmenpaket mit den
generalsekretären der landesparteien
beschlossen er stets zum dialog bereit
er wird den online konferenzen und vor
ort präsent sein in den landesverbänden
wir werden im november eine ost
konferenz veranstalten um die besonderen
strukturellen fragen des ostens wo die
afg unser größter gegner ist und wo wir
alles tun wollen sie wieder
zurückzudrängen wie das gelingen kann
wir werden darüber hinaus im dezember zu
einer kreisvorsitzendenkonferenz
einladen und wir werden eine interne
kommission zur aufarbeitung einsätzen in
der ehemalige und amtierende
bundestagsabgeordnete beteiligt sind
sowie mitglieder aus den landesverbänden
auch sachverstand von außen der einmal
genau analysieren wird was ist denn in
den letzten jahren schief gelaufen wo
müssen wir besser werden wo müssen wir
programmatisch besser werden wo müssen
wir im vorpolitischen raum besser werden
alle diese fragen gehören zur
aufarbeitung des wahlergebnisses
zur personellen zukunft und
neuaufstellung werde ich den gremien der
partei der kommenden woche die
einberufung eines parteitags vorschlagen
das ist der ort wo die 1001 delegierten
aus allen kreisverbänden sich
artikulieren können ort und datum werden
wir noch gemeinsam festlegen
und die personelle frage die dann an
steht braucht andere wege braucht
vielleicht
unkonventionelle wege wir haben seit
2008 10 seit dem rückzug von angela
merkel als parteivorsitzende
eine andauernde personaldebatte
immer gegeneinander immer in wechselnden
besetzungen und
wir wollen diesmal einen anderen weg
gehen wir wollen ein weg des konsenses
gehen und jeder ist auch klug sich jetzt
daran zu halten
in nordrhein westfalen in einem großen
landesverband der lange zerstritten war
ist dass in den letzten tagen gelungen
es gab mehrere interessenten für das amt
des landesvorsitzenden und des
ministerpräsidenten
oder der ministerpräsidentin und wir
haben in intensiven gesprächen erreicht
dass am ende alle auch die die eigene
interessen hatten die zurückgestellt
haben und sich auf einen kandidaten
verständigt der nun ende oktober zum
neuen ministerpräsidenten in nordrhein
westfalen und damit auch zum
vorsitzenden des größten landesverbandes
in der cdu gewählt werden soll mit
hendrik wüst und dieses beispiel
wollen wir auch in der bundes partei
versuchen einen konsens aller die im
moment in betracht kommen diesen prozess
werde ich moderieren und hierzu will ich
bereits in den kommenden wochen mit den
landesvorsitzenden der partei
beraten um auch da zu hören wie denkt
denn die jeweilige basis über diesen
künftigen prozess
welches profil soll denn dieser kandidat
oder die kandidatin haben und kann es
uns nicht diesmal gelingen dass wir eine
gemeinsame lösung für die aufstellung in
der opposition finden der wunsch danach
an der basis ist sehr groß das ziel dies
zu erreichen ist eine ambitionierte
aufgabe die ich mir vorgenommen habe
fazit in drei sätzen die cdu steht
weiter für jamaika bereit
wir arbeiten das wahlergebnis bereits
jetzt in der nächsten zeit intensiv auf
die personelle neuaufstellung
der cdu
vom vorsitzenden über das präsidium bis
hinein in den bundesvorstand werden wir
ebenfalls zügig anpacken mein ziel ist
es was immer in meinem leben mein ziel
war gegensätze zu versöhnen zu einer
gemeinsamkeit zu kommen
in unserem namen union ist das enthalten
und ich wäre froh wenn dass in dieser
schwierigen phase für die partei
gelingen würde dass wir mit neuen
persönlichkeiten einen neuanfang machen
ob am ende in regierung oder in
opposition ist dabei nicht die wichtige
frage die wichtige frage ist das eine
bürgerliche starke
volkspartei in europa
zu neuen erfolgen kommt und mit neuem
elan ihren beitrag leistet zur zukunft
des landes vielen dank
ja so weit also die erklärung von armin
laschet dem cdu parteivorsitzenden der
das auch erstmal bleiben wird das hat er
klargemacht wir fassen noch mal ganz
kurz zusammen er sagt mein herr aber
einfach anzuerkennen aus sicht der cdu
dass die grünen und die fdp jetzt nun
mal bestimmen mit wem verhandelt werde
er hat aber auch noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen dass jamaika als option
immer noch bestehen bleiben würde
personelle konsequenzen hat er jetzt
nicht direkt bezogen aber hat seine
bereitschaft kann man sagen signalisiert
sich irgendwann auch demnächst
zurückzuziehen wenn das so gewünscht
würde die wahlniederlage werde
aufgearbeitet werden das wird auch eine
kommission dazu eingesetzt werden und
was die personellen ich habe es gerade
angesprochen konsequenzen angeht das
soll dann auf einem parteitag
stattfinden wenn die gezogen werden
sollen da soll es dann um personelle
entscheidungen gehen dem prozess
insgesamt den möchte er aber gerne noch
moderieren und wir sprechen weiter mit
christian hübscher aus unserem
hauptstadtstudio ja das war also meine
kurze zusammenfassung christian ich
hoffe du kannst mir schon hören sehen
tue ich dich noch nicht ich kenne ich
sehr gut ok wohl aber christiane ja wie
hat armin laschet auf dich gewöhnt war
das jetzt für dich überraschend was er
gesagt hat ja du siehst mich tatsächlich
eigentlich sprachlos aber ich versuche
es trotzdem mal also was war das denn
jetzt eigentlich war das ein indirekter
rückzug war das ein ich ziehe mich vom
parteivorsitz zurück aber ich sag es
noch nicht so richtig also er hat diese
worte ja tatsächlich nicht ausgesprochen
hat nicht gesagt ich werde den cdu
vorsitz abgeben oder ich werde mich auf
absehbare zeit zurückziehen das hat er
tatsächlich nicht gesagt er hat sehr
verklausuliert
gesagt dass man einen prozess einberufen
möchte und zwar vom vorsitzenden hin bis
zum bundesvorstand wo man für eine
erneuerung sorgen möchte wie gesagt
bedeutet das alles nur an das bleibt
alles wahnsinnig schwammig aber ich
glaube wenn man ganz genau hinhört dann
hat er gesagt ja wir stoßen jetzt einen
prozess an mit was du aufgezählt das mit
einem bundesparteitag mit einer internen
kommission wo wir uns auch rat von außen
holen wollen und wir suchen uns einen
neuen parteivorsitzenden ich glaube ich
glaube das kann man so verstehen aber er
hat es nicht wirklich so gesagt das ist
richtig das ist in der tat erstaunlich
also man hatte da doch jetzt irgendwie
klarere worte noch erwartet andererseits
ist jetzt natürlich auch die frage er
hat ja skizziert wie es jetzt
weitergehen soll es gab die ganzen
letzten tage schon immer störfeuer und
auch kritik aus den eigenen reihen auch
an seiner person
das wird jetzt vermutlich durch diese
erklärung also ich weiß es nicht aber
wird das jetzt aufhören nein das glaube
ich nicht dass ich das beruhigt weil wie
gesagt das ist jetzt nicht der der harte
schnitt oder die befreit das ist nicht
der befreiungsschlag für die union denen
man sich da glaube ich erhofft sondern
das ist jetzt wieder so ein aussitzen
einer entscheidung oder sondern auf die
lange bank schieben einer entscheidung
und es ist fraglich ob das der union
hilft es ist die frage ob armin laschet
versucht auf diese art und weise eben
diese diese option jamaika tatsächlich
im rennen zu halten er hat ja gesagt das
projekt jamaika wird nicht scheitern an
der person armin laschet also das heißt
ich stehe da nicht im weg aber ich bin
gerne bereit da weiter mit das weiter
mit zu verfolgen diese idee und stehe
dazu gesprächen bereit sollte sich diese
ampel koalition dann doch am ende nicht
ausgehen aber ja also einen
befreiungsschlag sieht anders aus wir
werden jetzt heute abend sehen bis jetzt
kann ich das noch nicht sehen aber mit
sicherheit melden sie gibt es die ersten
wortmeldungen bald die das bewerten
werden auch innerhalb der union ja da
kann man sehr gespannt sein vielleicht
auch gerade auf die reaktion aus münchen
wer weiß was da jetzt direkt ankommen
wird im anschluss gerne potter hat über
youtube fragt uns wird laut der nun
seine politische laufbahn beenden bleibt
er abgeordneter so genau wird man das
jetzt noch nicht sagen können gute frage
also er hat einen er hat ja ein
bundestagsmandat mit dieser
bundestagswahl errungen ja und der
rückweg ist wieder alle wissen
spätestens allerspätestens seit gestern
verbaut indem er nämlich dort in
düsseldorf sein nachfolger als
ministerpräsident ja bereits
vorgeschlagen hat mit herrn wüst also
nach düsseldorf geht es nicht zurück er
bleibt in berlin er hat schon
angekündigt dass er nicht als
oppositionsführer zur verfügung steht
sondern darum werden um dieses wichtige
amt was womöglich auf die union jetzt
zukommt werden sich andere klappen
müssen sage ich mal so ganz erlaubt und
ja was bleibt für armin laschet man kann
es ganz schwer abschätzen es ist möglich
dass er am ende sich demnächst mit
martin schulz auf der hinterbank im
bundestag wieder findet ja das wäre
interessant muss man sagen in der tat
ein interessantes bild
ich gucke gerade noch nach weiteren
fragen wird dann erwartet dass sich
laschet heute noch das haben wir gerade
gesagt wegen seines vermuteten
rücktritts vor der kamera äußert also er
hat sich geäußert die äußerung das war
die äußerung genau aber von rücktritt
war eben noch nicht direkt die rede und
deswegen sind wir jetzt etwas an
spekulieren wie es nun weitergehen wird
er hat gesagt er würde den prozess dann
moderieren wollen und das ist ja auch
irgendwie in bild an das man sich ja
dann erstmal irgendwie gewöhnen muss
dass er der ja dann offenbar gescheitert
ist bei dem versuch selber kanzler zu
werden und auch noch nicht lange cdu
parteivorsitzender ist dann den prozess
moderiert seiner nachfolge ist ja so
sehr gewöhnt muss sich die union da gar
nicht die cdu denn tatsächlich hat es
das ja schon gegeben wir erinnern uns an
einem gerät kramp-karrenbauer als sie
quasi hingeschmissen hat übrigens mit
sehr viel deutlicheren worten sie hat
sehr viel klarer erklärt ich höre auf
und sie hat aber auch gesagt ich
moderiere den main ich moderiere die
suche eines nachfolgers und ihr erinnert
euch alle an diese quellen langen monate
in denen dann also röttgen märz und
sparen sich duellierten um den
parteivorsitz ja und das will das will
laschet jetzt ganz offensichtlich auch
aber wie das genau vonstatten gehen wird
ob man da jetzt mal es gab viele rufe
auch innerhalb der partei dass man die
mitglieder mehr einbinden soll ja einen
mit womöglich ein mitgliederentscheid
macht so wie die spd das ja vorgemacht
hat dieser weg ist glaube ich überhaupt
nicht klar jedenfalls hat ihnen armin
laschet heute nicht skizziert ja in der
tat also klar ist fällt auf die
parallelen auch zum fall kramp
karrenbauer aber da muss man ja dann
auch wohl festhalten und das hatte armin
laschet ja vorhin auch angedeutet
dass es da wohl doch ein strukturelles
problem gibt innerhalb der cdu dass sich
also im moment da offenbar mehrere
strömungen so ineinander verkeilt haben
das ist zumindest dem personal der
letzten zeit nicht gelungen ist da eine
gewisse stabilität reinzubringen ja das
kann man am allerbesten glaube ich
festmachen an dieser idee einer ost
konferenz im november glaube ich hat er
gesagt soll die stattfinden die cdu hat
gemerkt dass sie ein riesenproblem im
osten hat das speziell in thüringen und
in sachsen ihr natürlich viele
direktmandate flöten gegangen sind an
die afd
und in den anderen ostdeutschen
bundesländern natürlich auch vor allem
an die an die spd und es ist die frage
warum hat man den osten quasi nicht
verstanden und das soll jetzt also eine
ost konferenz klären ob das am ende der
heilsbringer ist kann ich nicht
beurteilen aber es ist ein hinweis
darauf dass man sieht aha wir haben ein
problem es gerade noch mal 2 kommentare
vor von frank berg olaf über youtube
scholz wird ein schwacher kanzler sein
grüne und fdp werden diktieren da immer
noch die option mit der union besteht
das muss man jetzt vielleicht will ein
bisschen relativieren klar formal
besteht sie noch aber dazu werde ich
dich gleich auch noch mal fragen und
marco schreibt beziehungsweise jasmin
huhn rücktritt wer bei flutkatastrophen
lacht hat nichts mit der regierung zu
suchen er soll endlich seine niederlage
eingestehen das ist vielleicht auch noch
mal so ein punkt auf den man noch mal
eingehen sollte also die
beliebtheitswerte von armin laschet die
wurden ja irgendwie immer schwächer auch
im verlaufe des wahlkampfs aber gerade
auch dann nach der wahl da war wirklich
der rückhalt in der bevölkerung für
ihnen eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr da
und musste er sich nicht auch irgendwie
dieser tatsache diesen umstand dann
irgendwann mal beugen und ist das ist
jetzt die konsequenz die jetzt ja ich
glaube genau das ist es ist jetzt der
vorschlag auf einem parteitag sozusagen
einen neuen
nachfolger zu wählen
ja und was und was jamaika betrifft weil
du es gerade ansprichst ich glaube es
ist natürlich mit dem heutigen tag und
mit dieser pressekonferenz von armin
laschet gerade und mit diesem
angekündigten indirekten rückzug nicht
wahrscheinlicher geworden sondern die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es am ende zu
einem jamaika bündnis kommt ist eher
kleiner geworden mit dieser
pressekonferenz gerade und mit diesem
angekündigten rückzug weil das natürlich
auf alle anderen parteien genau so
verstörend wirkt darf ich mal sagen wie
wahrscheinlich auch viele von uns dass
man sagt das ist das jetzt ist das jetzt
ein rücktritt oder keiner und und die
die fdp hat ja gestern schon gesagt wir
bauen damit erstaunen hin was was sich
da in der in der union tut
mir so leuten kann man quasi nicht nicht
verhandeln also willens keine führung
gibt wenn da ein machtvakuum ist an der
spitze der cdu dann wissen sie gar nicht
weniger ansprechen sollen in den
nächsten wochen irgendwie schon nach
armin laschet werden sie kein problem
auch nicht genau dieses problem ist ja
auch benannt worden in den letzten tagen
eben auch von vertretern beider parteien
vor allem immer auch auf der aus der fdp
und da will ich dann auch noch mal
nachfragen wollen also wenn der user
schreibt zwar gerade ja es gibt ja immer
noch die andere option deswegen seit
ostern dazu verurteilt ein schwacher
kanzler zu sein oder zumindest sich
irgendwie schwer durchsetzen zu können
in den verhandlungen aber wenn man das
jetzt noch mal gegenüber stellt das ist
ja gerade schon gesagt dann hat sich die
verhandlungsposition
insbesondere der fdp und da habe ich
eigentlich nicht verbessert denn die
rückfall option mit der union na ja also
das ist eher schwierig das stimmt also
das wird man jetzt nicht mehr so oft und
nicht mehr so laut und deutlich sagen
könnte dass man ja noch was anderes
machen könnte weil das andere nämlich
jamaika gerade irgendwie in
desolate desolates bild ab gibt ja also
das wirkt tatsächlich da hast du recht
die verhandlungsposition von christian
lindner ein stückweit schmälern das
glaube ich auch seine
verhandlungsposition ist ja interessant
ja also ich höre immer wieder dass ich
leute darüber gedanken mache macht ihr
das nochmal wie 2017 steht er auf und
geht wenn er nicht das kriegt was er
will ich selber glaube dass er das nur
noch schwer kann weil das wird er auch
seinen eigenen leuten quasi nicht mehr
verkaufen können dass er nochmal
verhandlungen ab bericht die fdp will
regieren die fdp muss regieren und ich
glaube sie wird sich irgendwie aufraffen
und es wird ein kompromisse geben mit
denen sie leben kann und dann wird sie
regieren vielleicht noch mal zum schluss
auf deiner einschätzung was die
nachfolge dann in der union angeht wem
träumst du da die besten chancen ein ist
das zu sehr jetzt der blick in die
glaskugel oder hättest du ja schon die
idee wer sich da jetzt im folgenden dann
doch gute karten ausrechnen könnte ja
ich das ist wirklich ein blick in die
glaskugel
ich habe ja vorhin schon gesagt die
ganzen namen dem von denen man jetzt
gerne hören und lesen würde von denen
habe ich jetzt noch nichts gelesen
vielleicht habe ich auch noch nicht
geschafft aber ja sohn jens sparen was
er jetzt macht oder ein friedrich merz
oder auch carsten linnemann wird der
mittelstandsvereinigung vorsitzen wird
immer wieder genannt das sind die namen
die dann sofort so im raum sind ja aber
was da jetzt genau passiert ist glaube
ich weiß noch nicht mal in der union
irgendjemand ganz genau und aber dass
die werden jetzt aus der deckung kommen
ich glaube das wird nicht lange dauern
dann werden sich die ersten aspiranten
melden was glaubst du dann woran armin
laschet gescheitert ist am ende
gute frage
so schwer zu beantworten ich glaube
natürlich ein stück weit an sich selbst
es wird über dieses legendäre lachen
dieses unpassende lachen da im
flutgebiet als turning point in dieser
in diesem ganzen wahlkampf angeführt der
ist bestimmt was dran von dem moment an
ging es wirklich bergab mit seinen
beliebtheitswerten weil die menschen
eben tatsächlich jemanden wählen von dem
sie glauben dass sie sich in bestimmten
situationen adäquat verhalten kann und
das hatte einen der stelle nicht gekonnt
obwohl es an vielen anderen stellen
sicher kann und bewiesen hat dass er es
kann
ja und
das ist alles spekulation
klar also sind mit sicherheit mehrere
faktoren die da zusammengekommen sind
vielleicht noch mal 2 kommentare zu ihm
an apps auch über youtube glaube
trotzdem dass willaschek mit laschet
besser gefahren wären so wie mit ihm
umgegangen worden ist finde ich das
nicht fair wir brauchen uns nicht über
andere länder aufzuregen da ist mit
sicherheit auch was dran also ich glaube
auch die darstellung natürlich jeder
macht fehler aber die darstellung seiner
person war teilweise schon recht hart
laschet soll doch gehen schreibt
wiederum smile über youtube soll das
gehen wenn man so viele wähler stimmt
verliert ist es eine arroganz noch
kanzler werden zu wollen macht sucht
macht hier und macht gier also keine
ahnung jedenfalls die orthographie ist
nicht ganz eindeutig da deutlich die
kritik noch mal an armin laschet dass er
doch ein das wahlergebnis bitte
anzuerkennen habe und naja nun ist es ja
offenbar so weit gekommen vielleicht
revier zum schluss noch mal ganz kurz
über die dreier konstellationen die ja
eigentlich jetzt heute unser anlass war
glaubst du die werden sich noch die
butter vom brot nehmen lassen wie
steinig wird der weg noch sein für die 3
für spd fdp und grüne in den nächsten
tagen und das klappt sie wie lange wird
das dauern ich glaube tatsächlich dass
das in der nächsten woche erst so
richtig interessant wird und wenn die
aber durchhalten was sie sich jetzt
vorgenommen haben nämlich nichts raus
bringen zu lassen dann wären wir leider
davon nicht so viel mitkriegen von
diesen kämpfen die da hinter
verschlossenen türen stattfinden aber es
gibt ja mindestens zwei themen bei denen
stich richtig knirschen könnte vor allem
zwischen grünen und fdp das ist zum
einen der klimaschutz und zum anderen
das thema steuern ja also wenn wir noch
mal kurz über den klimaschutz reden da
wird es glaube ich richtig schwierig für
die verhandler die grünen wollen die
klaren vorgaben durch den staat ja
manche sagen verbots partei also ab 2030
nur noch emissionsfreie autos zulassen
solaranlagen pflicht für dächer höhere
co2 preise für den verkehr
den kohleausstieg wollen die grünen auch
er da schon 2030 stadt 2038 wie
vereinbart die fdp ist wiederum gegen
also staatliche regulierungen und setzt
mehr auf die kräfte des marktes und wie
man das zusammen kriegen will das bedarf
wirklich guten verhandelns und am ende
wird es darauf rauslaufen dass jeder aus
seinem wahlprogramm
einen punkt oder ja ein paar punkte
umgesetzt bekommt aber natürlich nicht
alles ich glaube das ist den wählern
aber draußen auch wirklich klar niemand
erwartet in der dreier-koalition dass
die partei die er gewählt hat alles
durchbringen wird was was sie in ihr
wahlprogramm geschrieben hat ja es kommt
jetzt auf gutes verhandeln an und am
ende wird jeder ein paar punkte durch
kriegen und das ist auch wichtig dass
das muss so sein weil man muss dem
anderen den den beiden anderen partnern
jeweils erlauben dass sie sozusagen vor
ihre wähler treten können und sagen
können in diesem koalitionsvertrag
stehen folgende dinge nur drin weil wir
das wollten und das ist das wird jetzt
die nächste woche zeigen ich bin mir
nicht sicher wie viel wir davon
mitbekommen werden also an irgendeinem
punkt wird die vertraulichkeit womöglich
mal bröckeln bis jetzt tut sie das ja
nicht bei diesen drei parteien ja die
alten echt dicht ob sie das über wochen
durchhalten
wir werden es sehen du hast aber was
dieses thema angeht in inside politics
einen sehr sehenswerten beitrag gemacht
zu diesem ganzen thema zu den konkreten
verhandlungen jetzt aber auch zu
verhandlungsführung insgesamt das ganze
ist zu sehen unter anderem in der zdf
mediathek und auf youtube du hast
gesprochen mit einem experten für
wirtschaftspsychologie und eben auch für
verhandlungsführung und er erklärt noch
mal sehr anschaulich wie man vorgehen
muss in diesen gesprächen damit sie eben
zum erfolg geführt werden können so
darauf wenn wir gerne noch mal hinweisen
an die seite der insight politics genau
also von und mit christiane hütter ich
danke dir ganz herzlich für die
einschätzung heute abend hier bei uns
für eine menge besprochen wir hatten
eigentlich noch viel anderes vor aber
das war jetzt aufgrund der aktuellen
arbeit sind die genauen haben noch
möglich aber wir sind finde ich gut
durch die aktualität jetzt hier gekommen
mit dir zusammen danke schön nochmal
dafür einen schönen abend an dich und
das auch an unsere user natürlich und
zuschauer auch an euch einen schönen
abend jetzt um 19 uhr im zdf im
fernsehen geht es natürlich dann auch
noch mal weiter da auch nochmal
zusammenfassung und analysen der
gegenwärtigen situation dankeschön fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten abend
zschau